let's take a quick look at the South
Park destruction of Megan and Harry just
because it's so funny
it's been several months now since I've
been Queen has died our Canadians are
finding it hard to go on all Canadians
that is except for our first Guest The
Prince and his wife
thanks for having us on the show
now there are rumors they might be
saying because they sue everybody
everything normally especially if it's
true or if people are being intrusive
because they want to save it for
themselves so they can intrude in their
own lives uh Rob do you care about these
two well not really but I'm married so I
have to pay attention to a little bit so
I read some of the some of the stuff
online just to see about it but
something like this though it's one of
those things where you should just
deflate the argument okay it was funny I
made South Park that's cool we're doing
well financially other places I think if
Harry sees this which that you know he
might if someone sends him a clip he'll
probably see him at all but he can't the
thing about these two Louise they can't
laugh at themselves